WE'LL SEE A LOT OF THAT AVOY, TC
MADE.
>> HERE'S TJ.
>> AFTER REVIEW, THE CALL ON THE
ICE IS
REAL INTEGRAL PARTO JENSEN.
THAT SHOT DID NOT GET TH BACK O
SIDE.
McAVOY.
CROSS ICE PASS.
SHEARY GOT A STICK ON IT PLAY,
GOT TO HIT THE NET.
BY CSHEARY .
ENDS UP GETTINORLOV.
AND NOW AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
FOLIGNO AND OUT IN FRONT, THEY
PATIENCE HERE BY FOLIGNO,
GOALTENDER GETS WANDERING AND
ON THE BOARDS.
LAZAR WITH THE PUCK.
HE'S HILL BYDLE.
BOUNCING PUCK.
BACK UE HECK OF A SHOT.
BRUINS WITH THE LEAD.
>> THEY'RE MMANTHA.
INTO THE SLOT.
SHOT BY ELLER.
SCORE. ANDE CATS
AND MAKES AN INCREDIBL.
SCORE.TRYING
TO GET BACK TO THE WEAK SIDE TO
TO.
KUZNETSOV THOUGHT THEY SHOULD
HAVE HAD SKATES SENT ALONG BY N
INTO THE EMPTY NET.
UNSELFISH PLAY THERE B